foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar titled
artificial intelligence and multi-omics
in perinatal period this webinar is part
of the 2022 microbiology virtual week
event and I'm Susie Valdez of lab roots
and I will be your moderator for today's
event so let's get started before we
begin I want to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to First participate by
communicating with other attendees in
our new live chat feature during the
presentation you can find that live chat
located on the right of your screen you
can also participate by submitting as
many questions as you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
submit if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation simply click
click on the help desk button located at
the bottom of your screen within the
navigation bar or from the lobby and
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
that continuing education credits link
located in the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits I now
present today's speaker Dr Joseph Noy
for a complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
left of your screen Dr Noy welcome you
me now begin your presentation
I'd like to thank the organizers for
inviting me to give this lecture uh the
title of this lecture is artificial
intelligence and multi-omics in the
perinatal period
and the agenda for the next 40 or so
minutes is this follows I'm going to
give a brief background on artificial
intelligence and machine learning I'll
give a brief background on multiomix and
then I'll talk about how we can mesh
artificial intelligence with multiomics
and Diagnostics and Therapeutics in
maternal fetal medicine and in
neonatology and then I will just touch
upon where we are going in the future
let me start with this slide uh
many years ago in the early 1940s a very
famous author by the name of Isaac
Asimov wrote a series of books called
iRobot
and this series of books depicted uh
robots with intelligence who one could
actually communicate with and at that
time certainly that this was not uh
possible in reality but it was uh
something that was just in the mind of
uh the readers and also Isaac Asimov so
it was just fiction at the time
in the 1940s also uh in the early 40s
there was a major war going on World War
II and uh the uh German uh military had
this code called the Enigma code which
uh carried important information uh that
was uh critical for moving the uh uh
War forward for the German army but uh
this person here on the bottom right
this is uh Dr Alan Turing was able to
use some mathematics developed by some
Polish uh
mathematicians to break this Enigma code
and he is now known as the father of uh
the modern computer and one of his
quotes was I propose to consider the
question can machines think
well that was the 1940s and we've come a
long way since the 1940s
in 2022 a device worn around our wrists
carries exponentially more Computing
capability than devices that required
large cooled rooms in the 1950s
we now are having self-driving Vehicles
facial and voice recognition and the
ability to connect classrooms worldwide
and also the integration of human
cognition with the rapid processing of
artificial intelligence and these are
all examples of these major advances
that have taken place in these last few
decades
in medicine
we've also made considerable progress
now here this slide shows three eras of
medicine the past present and future
so in the past
we relied largely on intuition medicine
so for example in my field in
neonatology
we think that premature babies have
immature immune systems so we have to
use antibiotics a lot in these babies
and in fact antibiotics are given to
almost every premature baby weighing
less than uh 1500 grams in most neonatal
intensive care units in the world
but this is intuition based we don't
know if this is really the right thing
to do
in the present we are now undergoing
some uh associative studies uh uh
epidemiologic studies and also
prospective randomized trials that are
hopefully telling us whether this is a
good practice or not
in the future
we hope to be able to use Precision
medicine in other words
be able to get information from each
individual patient and be able to tell
whether that patient should be getting
antibiotics or not and this will be an
algorithmic based approach
so here are some of the different modes
of artificial intelligence we have
Predictive Analytics which rely on a
technique called machine learning we
have uh text to speech and speech to
text we have image recognition and uh at
the bottom we see additional forms of
artificial intelligence which are just
in the uh very early stages of being
applied to Medicine
in terms of Publications
related to Medicine
when we talk about multiomics and
artificial intelligence this is a slide
that shows a logarithmic scale and the
increase in various Publications in
these areas over the past uh 12 or so
years
so marked increase in interest and
Publications in these areas
now here's a picture of a type of a baby
that I take care of in the neonatal
Intensive Care Unit
and this is a fertile area for
artificial intelligence and multi-omic
applications
for example we want to be able to use
predictive analytic analytics
Diagnostics especially when coupled with
multiomics and also Precision
nutritional support
and I want to give you just some
examples of these uh applications
now here's a fellow who you might
recognize he is now 72 years old but
when I was growing up this was little
Stevie Wonder he was a child prodigy and
a musician and he had some very famous
songs and he's wearing sunglasses and
the reason he's wearing sunglasses is
not to be cool
reason he's wearing sunglasses is
because he is blind
he is blind because he has a disease
called retinopathy of prematurity
retinopathy of prematurity was first
recognized in the late 1940s
in an increased suddenly in premature
infants in the late 1940s
in the early 1950s it was found to be
associated with routine High oxygen
exposure enclosed in incubators
it was initially called retro lentil
fibroplasia
but as more was learned the name changed
to retinopathy of prematurity
if you look closely at the picture at
the top here you see that this baby has
very cloudy looking uh uh eyes the uh
pupils of the eyes look cloudy the
reason for that is because the retinas
have detached and that causes this
cloudy looking appearance and once the
retina is detach from the backs of the
eyes the baby is likely to be blind
now
we have some newer techniques utilizing
artificial intelligence that help us in
terms of uh diagnosis of this
retinopathy of prematurity
we are able to look at pictures of the
backs of the eyes
and rather than having different
ophthalmologists have a different
impression of what the retina looks like
we now have algorithms that really tell
us with a high degree of accuracy the
stage of retinopathy of prematurity
and to look at the features in the backs
of the eyes and the retina using these
techniques is actually beginning to be
more accurate than the diagnosis made by
the ophthalmologist
we also have a terrible disease entity
that we see in premature babies I should
call this a diagnosis rather than a
disease and this is uh called
necrotizing enterocolitis and here is a
picture of a baby on the top left that
has a distended abdomen and you see a
little bit of uh redness around the
belly button this baby had x-ray taken
and the two arrows are pointing to
features that are common in this disease
the bottom Arrow points to air in the
bowel wall and the top Arrow points to
air in the liver
this may be continued to do worse and
worse and then was taken to surgery and
at the bottom left you can see what this
Baby's intestine looked like at surgery
the arrow points to a necrotic piece of
intestine and that was resected and the
baby did uh did well after the reception
however
about 20 to 30 percent of the babies
with uh the surgical form of necrotizing
enterocolitis end up dying of this
disease
we also are beginning to recognize as I
mentioned before that this is uh uh a
diagnosis and not a discrete clinical
entity we do not have a good definition
of this disease at this time and we lump
several different entities under the
umbrella term of necrotizing
intercollitus
we have not made very much progress
because of this and we also have animal
models that have been studied that
really don't represent the disease that
we see in humans and we've had narrow
focus on individual Pathways rather than
systems and so we have not made very
much progress in this uh uh with uh
helping predict this diagnosis or uh
preventing it
here are just some of the imposters of
what we are calling necrotizing in our
colitis and so there are several
different entities that fall under the
umbrella here
work that we did at the University of
Florida uh just in the past couple of
years
involved uh looking at babies who have
uh uh what
we uh consider to be spontaneous
intestinal perforation versus the true
necrosis of the intestine
and on this slide we see that using
machine learning techniques
we have been working on trying to be
able to utilize features of these two
different entities that are called
necrotizing enterocolitis
uh to be able to tell whether this is
true necrotizing enterocolitis versus
spontaneous intestinal perforation
before the surgeon actually goes in and
takes a look
and so
uh
this slide
shows the uh uh baby with the
spontaneous intestinal perforation and
here again is the more classic form of
necrotizing and our colitis the way we
studied this was to take a large number
of babies who had a exploratory
laparotomies and we were able to take 40
patients who actually underwent the
laparotomy and clearly showed surgical
necrosis of the intestine versus the
spontaneous intestinal perforation and
then using
um
machine learning we were able to find
certain features
as seen at the bottom right here certain
features that fit more with one form of
this uh uh problem versus the other form
of the problem and so we did two
different kinds of machine learning uh
models and both of these machine
learning models were able to separate uh
the necrotizing enterocolitis the true
necrotizing enterocolitis from the
spontaneous intestinal perforation with
a high degree of certainty
so what does this mean
this means that rather than going in and
operating to try to find out what this
baby actually has
the surgeon can predict with a high
degree of accuracy whether this is a
spontaneous intestinal perforation or
necrotizing enterocolitis for
spontaneous intestinal perforation it is
easier to just put a little drain into
the abdominal cavity rather than doing a
full laparotomy and that drain will then
drain the uh peritoneal cavity and the
little hole will heal over and the baby
should do fine with just that procedure
relatively simple procedure rather than
opening the abdominal cavity completely
so this can be very helpful for the
Pediatric surgeon to discern these two
different forms of intestinal injury
next I'd like to talk a little bit more
about multiomics
and if we talk about omics probably the
first omic that we think about is the
genome or genomics and uh uh genomics is
something that has burgeoned over the
past several decades we now are able to
uh evaluate our human genome uh very
rapidly we can uh some of the
Laboratories that do human genomic
sequencing are able to uh get uh DNA
from an individual and they're able to
sequence this and provide the uh
sequence in less than a day so
tremendous progress has been done has
been made in genomics
but there are other forms of omics
one of these forms is called the
microbiome
and this has stemmed from work in
genomics some of the technology
developed in the Human Genome Project
has been applied to uh microbial DNA
sequencing an RNA sequencing and we have
several different forms of
microbiome sequencing Technologies one
of these is called 16s sequencing which
looks at a small portion of the
microbial Genome of 15 1500 nuclear base
region and this is very helpful in
telling us the types of microbes that
are there the relative abundance of
microbes that are there the diversity of
the microbes so it can be very helpful
to some extent but it doesn't tell us
what the uh actual potential the
physiologic potential of those microbes
are it just tells us uh their relative
abundance and who might be there whole
genome sequencing on the other hand
looks at the entire microbial genome and
the databases that are available for
whole genome sequencing can tell us much
more about what the actual potential of
these uh microbes are what they are
doing in the uh uh Niche that they are
in
so we have applied microbiome sequencing
to evaluate necrotizing enterocolitis
and the types of microbes that are
present prior to the development of uh
this diagnosis
and here we see these two graphs at the
top and the graph at the left represents
a time period with babies at 24 25 to 36
weeks gestation and the colors represent
a different phyla of bacteria
these are the control babies and on the
right we see the necrotizing and our
colitis babies the NEC babies
and one can see that the NEC babies over
time from 24 to 35 weeks if we sequence
their microbiome we see differences
compared to the controls the Blue
appears to increase these are a certain
volume of bacteria called the
proteobacteria
the yellow the dark yellow begins to
decrease
and these are bacteria called the
bacterides
we know that uh the proteobacteria are
bacteria that have a lot of uh
lipopolysaccharide this is a uh an agent
in their cell walls that stimulates an
inflammatory response and so we are
seeing more of these uh potentially
pathogenic microbes develop prior to the
diagnosis of this disease and then the
uh light or the dark yellow represents
the firmicutes and or I'm sorry the yes
the firmicutes and these firmicutes
produce
a certain
types of short chain fatty acids that
are known to be protective in the
gastrointestinal tract so this is
telling us that there is an association
between the types of microbes in the
gastrointestinal tract of these babies
before the development of the disease
however
this is an association
and it doesn't tell us whether this is
actually causing the disease so when
studies like this find an association
between two things it does not mean that
one thing caused the other to happen
so how can we get by this and this is
where multiomics comes in
and I really like to explain multi-omics
using this Parable and it's the parable
of the six Blind Men of Hindustan
each one of these Blind Men of Hindustan
was asked to feel this structure
and one of the Blind Men went to the
side of this structure and said this
feels like a wall
the other blind man went to uh the back
of the structure and said this feels
like a rope uh the other blind man went
to the uh front of the animal or in
front of this structure and said this
feels like a spear and so forth and all
these uh Blind Men came back and they
were dogmatic in what they felt
they didn't talk to one another
they didn't really collaborate
and this was problematic because they
were not able to determine that this was
truly an elephant
had they talked to one another
collaborated they would have been able
to tell if this was an elephant and this
is where multi-omics comes in
and individually multi each one of these
omics for example the genome can be very
helpful
but you can have
genomic mutations and genomic variations
which are never truly expressed unless
you have certain environmental
conditions that come in and cause that
genomic uh sequence to be expressed and
then you can see that in the
transcriptome and the proteome in the
metabolum and so one can look at these
different omics under different
conditions over time and integrate them
and they can much more strongly identify
patterns associated with disease and
even causative of a disease or outcome
and once we have this this can lead more
readily lead to a preventative or
therapeutic targets
here
see how different layers of these omics
are placed on one another and you can
start with a phenotype or you can start
with a gene a genome first uh techniques
and you put them together and you find
this uh pattern that can develop with
these different nodes that we see these
circles and colors and uh the larger
they are the the larger these are in
this mechanistic modeling the greater is
the interaction
and so using the systems biology
integration of omics data
we can now
much more readily look at
uh the uh these uh omics and be able to
uh evaluate mechanisms of disease
so here is just one example
uh inflammatory bowel disease and this
is a study that was published a few
years ago to evaluate what happens when
you look at single omics with single
omics you can get secondary analyzes as
I mentioned before you will get uh
associations but if you put these omics
together and you do you integrate them
you get primary mechanisms so much much
better than uh uh when you look at a
single omics approach in terms of
defining mechanisms of the disease
so here we get back to this little
premature baby a 25-week gestation
intrauterine growth restricted female
this is telling us that this baby
probably had poor nutrition in utero and
how do we nourish this baby
well in the past using the Paradigm that
I mentioned before we would say well we
have these uh uh
formulas available for premature babies
that can be used but all of the formulas
are pretty much the same for premature
babies we have uh Mother's Milk which
could be used
this doesn't tell us very much about uh
that particular baby and what is best
for that particular baby
we're currently undergoing all kinds of
studies to try to use evidence-based
medicine to provide information on how
to best nourish a baby like this but in
the future
we will be able to say this was an
intrauterine growth restricted baby this
is a girl this is a baby who had an
infection at Birth and put all those
features together and be able to tell
what is the most appropriate nutrition
for that particular baby
we are beginning to recognize that
precision and nutrition is something
that is very important because we do not
all respond the same to the same food
intake
this is a study that was published in
nature medicine a couple of years ago
where they looked at identical twins and
gave these identical twins very similar
diets and then they looked at
triglyceride
glucose responses various nutritional
responses and they found that these
twins had different responses to the
same nutrients
but they found that there was a very
high correlation to the type of microbes
present in the gastrointestinal tract of
these twins and the uh
responses
were highly uh correlated to the types
of microbes present in the
gastrointestinal tract
so when it comes to nutrition
why personalized well here we have two
different types of premature babies a 23
week pre-term and a 29 week pre-term and
the type of nutrition we need to give
these babies is very different because
one size does not fit all and we should
be able to prevent some of the very
adverse outcomes that we see in these
babies by providing better nutrition
from these babies for these babies early
on
now
we can provide different forms of
formulas to these uh babies we can
provide a baby's own mother's milk or we
can provide donor milk
baked donor milk to these babies but we
are beginning to recognize that baby's
own Mother's Milk provides for the
greatest Precision Nutrition and on this
slide we see results of a study that
were published in 2011 where 16
different uh
milk 16 different Mothers Milk samples
were taken at three different time
periods and each one of these
um represents uh each one of these s's
represents a different mother
and
uh we have these Columns of colors that
represent one week two weeks and four
weeks after birth and we see that the
colors differ markedly from one mother
to the other
so the composition the microbial
composition which represents the colors
that we see here are very different from
one mother to the next
so this is suggesting that the types of
microbes that we find in mother's milk
may be uh very much uh
Precision oriented for that particular
baby
why do I say that
in terms of personalization uh the
baby's own mother's milk over time is uh
considered to be a highly personalized
uh type of nutrition and one of the
reasons is seen here something called
the intro memory immune system where the
mother and the baby if they have close
contact with one another the baby's
immune system may not be very well yet
developed yet but the mothers is and so
what happens is that any microbes that
the baby is
affected or colonized with will get into
the mother's mouth by kissing the baby
or being very close to the baby and that
will get into the mother's
gastrointestinal tract where her mucosal
immune system sets up in an immune
response
that then gets transmitted to the milk
and the baby will uh drink that mother's
milk and takes take in some of the
immunoglobulins that are specific for
that particular uh microbe that the uh
baby may be colonized by so this is one
of the uh rationales for uh seeing
different types of microbes in different
samples of milk again this says not yet
been uh fully tested uh in in terms of
rigorous studies but it seems to uh be a
very good strong hypothesis that needs
further testing
uh work that we have done uh in our
Laboratories uh two pictures here uh Dr
uh Nicole Cacho who is a postdoctoral
fellow at the time and Dr Graziano Lorca
at the bottom she is a uh professor of
microbiology at the University of
Florida we did some studies looking at
the personalization of the microbiota of
donor human milk with the mother's own
milk well donor human milk comes from
lots of mothers and it is pasteurized in
the uh microbes are killed by this
pasteurization process and that may
actually be problematic in donor milk
that you are not providing microbes
and these microbes may actually be very
helpful so one of the things we did in
uh this study that was published in
Frontiers in microbiology in 2017 was to
take small amounts of the baby's own
Mother's Milk put that into donor milk
and uh allow that to incubate for
different periods of time and we found
that the incubation period between four
to eight hours resulted in a uh
refination of the donor milk and a
profile of microbes that look very much
the same as the baby's own mother's milk
we also looked at the metabolites and
found that the metabolites uh seen here
in these uh principal component plots
that uh we were able to make the
metabolites look much
more like the baby's own mother's milk
if they were uh provided with some of
the a small amount of the uh mother's
milk into the uh donor milk larger donor
milk samples
so this is telling us that uh we may be
able to do some personalization and this
is a
one of the pathways toward
personalization of uh donor milk in the
future
now how do we currently monitor
nutrition in our premature babies well
one way is to use these growth curves as
seen here on the chart and we can see
that uh we should be following these
growth curves but these dark lines
represent growth faltering
this means that the baby is not growing
the way the baby should
problematic
because once we see this kind of growth
faltering it is probably already late in
the kind of damage that this growth
faltering can cause for this Baby's
entire lifetime can be problematic
we need good indicators that help
prevent this
the growth curves are gaussian
distributions and they are certainly not
personalized so we need to do something
to be able to personalize nutrition and
this is something that we are starting
to work on uh using artificial
intelligence for prediction of growth
failure and here's a reference that was
recently published in a biomedical
bioinformatics and uh here we developed
a model that integrates clinical and
microbiome data
and the clinical and microbiome data was
derived from a large British cohort and
three cohorts in the United States and
we compare different models to uh
uh get uh data on what would be the best
clinical predictors of growth faltering
and we also found that uh information on
the kind of taxonomy in the uh of
microbes in the gastrointestinal tract
may actually be helpful for us to
predict this growth faltering and so
this told us that we need to move
further and perhaps even take a
multi-ohmic approach uh in uh being able
to do this so what kind of studies do we
have planned in the future
Well we'd like to be able to get timed
infant samples from Theses saliva blood
and urine and then look at the
microbiome look at immune and
inflammatory markers and metabolomics
and proteomics and put them together
into this network analysis and then be
able to uh
delineate the different diseases that
might develop or
adverse outcomes that might develop
depending on the type of nutrition we
can then also do biomarker Discovery and
then this could potentially lead to
personalized therapeutic interventions
we still have a long ways to go with
this but I think that the tools are
there
so
here's a summary and where we are going
in the future
the causal nature of single omic
associations are not well understood but
they are amenable to analysis by newly
developing Technologies such as
multiomics and artificial intelligence
once these mechanisms are understood we
will better be able to provide
Predictive Analytics and personalized
nutrition
for mothers and infants
and in order to accomplish this we need
to have teams of scientists we need to
have clinicians basic scientists
engineers and bioinformaticians working
together and communicating and working
as a team to be able to uh move forward
and have positive accomplishments in the
these areas thank you for your attention
and thank you Dr Noy for that time today
and your important research and before
we go I want to thank our audience for
joining us today as well questions
submitted today and during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration and this
webcast can be viewed on demand for two
years until September 6 2024. lab routes
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time take care everyone
bye-bye